when it comes to the israeli-palestinian
conflict it feels like it's always the
same story
Israel launching an airstrike
Palestinian teenager was shot and killed
by Israeli soldiers a settler couple
driving in the north of the West Bank
when he was shorted when a Palestinian
or Israeli is killed it's a tragedy for
their family and community but there's
an important part of that story that's
usually missing the occupation
Israel has maintained a military
occupation of Palestinian territories
since 1967 that's meant Israel has taken
over Palestinian lands and built
settlements on them for its population
in violation of international law Israel
also heavily restricts the movement of
Palestinians and controls their economy
and even water and electricity
Palestinians living under Israeli
occupation don't get a vote or a say in
the system that dominates their lives
but here's the bottom line
violence is an inevitable result of
occupation the killings the clashes the
stabbings the home demolitions the
checkpoints the night raids the Rockets
none of these things happen in a vacuum
is Raya less displaced Palestinians from
their land demolish their homes and kept
them in refugee camps whether
Palestinians protest violently or not
Israel frequently responds with military
force that's what an occupation is so
can the violence in the occupied
Palestinian territories end without an
end to the occupation follow the
palestinian-israeli conflict and you'll
hear that settlements are a major
sticking point well what exactly are
they